[Music]
on this Thursday night Russia fires a
missile into a Ukrainian Grocery Store
and Cafe the casualties of this
coldblooded
attack as Western leaders try to shore
up support for Ukraine ottawa's plan to
bring down grocery prices food for us is
a luxury we reality check what's being
promised the heat was on the alarm
sounded over the world's hottest ever
September and what happens in Vegas
started in Canada it was like nothing
I've ever seen before shedding light on
Montreal's connection to this
technological
Marvel global national with Donna FZ
good evening and thanks for joining us
if the world needed reminding about
Russia's war in Ukraine it got it today
a Russian missile strike killed at least
51 people including a child in a village
near an Eastern Ukrainian City people
had gathered there for a memorial
service when it happened a warning the
images are disturbing the gruesome task
of covering bodies followed hours of
searching for survivors Ukrainian
president viadimir zalinski condemned
the attack as a deliberate Act of
terrorism he is in Spain talking to
European leaders about strengthening
Ukraine's air defenses just yesterday
the American President Joe Biden
expressed concern the political chaos in
Congress could disrupt the flow of
American Aid to Ukraine Crystal ganing
has our top story on one of the
deadliest Russian attacks since the
start of its full-scale
Invasion this shop and Cafe in HOSA were
busy filled with community members
attending a
funeral a soldier was being buried says
this woman who heard about the strike
and rushed to the scene knowing her
mother was there residents and emergency
workers call HED the rubble Carnage and
corpses Hallmarks of the Russian
invasion speaking at an event in Sochi
Russia President Vladimir Putin
described it as a so-called war and said
it was not started by Russia but the
West's need for an enemy and said Europe
was supporting Ukraine to the detriment
of its economy Banning the Flames of War
fatigue European leaders meeting in
Spain put on a united front with Ukraine
cities children of every country deserve
to be secure and everywhere in the
country not just in the subway not just
in the shelters underground but
everywhere a young boy was one of the
victims of the strike on
heroa it's now one of the deadliest
single attacks on civilian
infrastructure since the start of
Russia's fullscale Invasion what happens
next largely depends on the United
States Democrats and some Republicans
are fighting over the money spent
supporting Ukraine American President
Joe Biden says he's planning to give a
major speech on the issue and the White
House Press Secretary used the tragedy
to justify its position uh we have to be
continue to support the people of
Ukraine because this is the horrifying
nature that they live in every day 3
days of mourning was announced by the
governor of the har oblast families of
loved ones who are attending the funeral
are now having to organize burials Donna
crystal ganing in London thanks Crystal
a big reversal from the American
President Joe Biden on his promise to
never build another foot of border wall
between Mexico and the United States
facing a surge of migrants into the US
Biden has backed away from that hard
line today he waved a number of federal
regulations allowing construction of the
border wall to resume the wall former
president Donald Trump made a
Cornerstone of his presidency Joel senk
explains why Biden did it and the
political challenge the migrant crisis
poses the constant stream of migrants
will soon face more barriers when
Crossing from Mexico to the US President
Joe Biden's Administration is waving
over two dozen federal laws to expand
the border wall in Texas even as
officials speak out against their own
move we believe that there are better
effect ways of moving forward to secure
our border and security the new
construction could add over 30 km to the
border wall the President says the money
was allocated during Donald Trump's term
in 2019 and had to be spent now there's
nothing under the law other than they
have to use the money for what it was
appropriate I can't stop that the move
flies in the face of the president's
past words as a candidate he said his
administration would not construct
another foot of border wall former
president Trump speaking out on social
media writing in part will Joe Biden
apologize to me and America for taking
so long to get
moving and in Mexico president Andreas
Manuel Lopez obor calling the move a
step backwards that doesn't solve the
migrant
crisis and the problem is a stark one
felt across the US Mexican officials say
just last week 10,000 people a day
reached the Border those who make it
across are flooding cities at a crushing
Pace stretching resources to the Limit
from Denver when it's not nine buses a
day it's four buses a day it's five
buses a day to Chicago We're not here
saying we're against individual people
who cross this border we're mad at our
government for putting them against us a
former top US immigration official says
a resolution will take more than
physical barriers even after we catch
you and even after we process you we end
up having to release you because we
can't get a court date for you to you
know for a judges he your claim immigr
ation will likely be a major campaign
issue in the upcoming race for the White
House and while President Biden says he
does not believe border walls work the
move to build more could bring more
criticism from his left leaning base
opposed to more construction Donna Joel
senic in Washington thanks an
unprecedented Espionage trial is
underway in an Ottawa courtroom Cameron
ortis who was once a high-ranking RCMP
intelligence official is facing up to 14
years in prison accused to breaching
National Security when he was arrested
he was a rising star in the force and
had access to some of Canada's most
closely guarded information the crown
alleges he tried to sell that
information to criminals tya isri
explains what evidence the prosecution
is laying
out the case against Cameron ordis
revolves around a trove of secret emails
now uncovered explain the emails that
were presented today the email for
AUD not going to make any comments now
the the XR CMP intelligence director
left an Ottawa courtroom with his lawyer
who would not answer when asked about
the alleged correspondence between ordis
and Vincent Ramos a convicted criminal
that's one thing uh that really makes
this striking and there's a lot of email
Communications there uh you know and on
the face of it looks very damning Ramos
ran a vancouver-based company called
Phantom secure selling untraceable
phones to organized criminals the Crown
alleges ordis reach out to him in 2015
with a business proposition in the
agreed statement of facts someone under
the Alias see all things sent this email
Mr Ramos you do not know me I have
information I am confident you will find
very valuable at the time Ramos was the
target of Canadian and American police
the cost for this material relating is
$20,000 Canadian in cash to be hand
delivered at a pre-arranged time and
place the the FBI arrested Ramos in Las
Vegas in 2018 his emails eventually LED
RCMP to one of their own ortis was taken
into custody in
2019 his defense team will argue ortis
had the authority to release the
information allegedly sent to Ramos but
it has yet to present evidence as to why
Mr ortis will get his opportunity when
he gets to testify and uh it'll all be
explained this National Security and
intelligence expert says explaining that
to to a jury won't be easy they'll have
to be able to provide evidence that that
uh someone um high up in the
RCMP proposed this mission ortis is
expected to take the stand in his own
defense he's also chosen a jury instead
of a judge only trial which National
Security Experts say is especially rare
teria isri Global News
Ottawa in Toronto the families of two
women who were murdered almost 40 years
ago are finally getting Justice their
killer had for decades eluded police
thanks to DNA evidence he was arrested
earlier this year and today he pleaded
guilty back in 1983 Susan Ty a social
worker and mother of four and Aaron
Gilmore an aspiring fashion designer
were found dead in their homes within
months of each other both had been
sexually assaulted and stabbed to death
Global's crime specialist Katherine
McDonald
reports Joseph Southerland admitted in a
courtroom Tuesday that 40 years ago he
killed two women 4 kilm and 4 months
apart a huge relief for the family of
one of the victims who hugged police
outside Court after southernland pleaded
guilty to two counts of second deegree
murder it's been an amazing end to what
I think was you know basically finding a
lottery ticket in the street according
to the agreed statement of facts on
August 16th 1983 45-year-old Susan Ty
was alone at home on Gray Street when
southernland broke in attacked her in
her bedroom and sexually assaulted her
through forced intercourse before
stabbing her 13 times with a knife on
December 20th of that same year
southernland broke into Aaron Gilmore's
second floor apartment on Hazelton
Avenue after finding a door a jar the
22-year-old was found lying on her bed
her mouth gagged her hands bound behind
her back a belt around her neck she'd
also been sexually assaulted and stabbed
twice in the chest police announced in
the year 2000 that both women had been
murdered by the same man because the DNA
profile from the Seaman samples matched
but it wasn't until 20 21 that the
Southerland family and in particular
five brothers were identified as Persons
of Interest thanks to genetic genealogy
according to the facts after the
elimination of four out of the five
Southerland Brothers as the source of
the crime scene DNA a DNA warrant was
executed by the Toronto police who
attended M and took blood samples from
Joseph southernland card southernland
returned home and contacted a friend a
retired op officer and confessed to
committing the two murders that retired
op officer immediately contacted the
bosses from the op who were in contact
with us and it we were able to arrange
in short order Mr uh Southerland turning
himself in Southerland sat quietly in
court Thursday he faces life in prison
with no chance of parole between 10 and
25 years they'll never bring Aaron back
or Susan t for that matter but it's also
at the same time it's a little bit of uh
closure for both of us and the rest of
our family and aon's friends knowing
that you know this guy's being put away
for hopefully a long time a sentencing
hearing has been scheduled for December
at which time Victim Impact statements
will be heard and southernland himself
will be given a chance to address the
court Katherine McDonald global
news we learned a little more today
about what progress is being made on the
federal government's promise to bring
down soaring food prices a month ago
senior cabinet ministers met with the
heads of Canada's five largest grocery
store chains they were asked to present
a plan about how they intend to
stabilize prices and the deadline was
Thanksgiving as can adans prepare to
cook their turkeys Mackenzie gray looks
at what people can
expect the Liberals sold it as their
plan to save Thanksgiving from high
grocery prices Canadians will be able to
see roll out of actions such as discount
across a basket of food products uh
price freezes and price matching
campaigns to name a few those measures
promised by Canada's five biggest
grocery stores to stabilize rocketing
food costs but price match and freezes
that's why lav LA's weekly specials are
on everyday items have been in Canadian
grocery ads for decades the minister
responsible couldn't give any specifics
on how this is different but believes
the Grocer's plan is already working you
I've been looking at some flyers this
morning and you already see action uh in
terms of different Grocers adjusting
ahead obviously of Thanksgiving but if
you look at the old Flyers there's been
no change with Canada's largest grocery
chain on a thanks giving staple turkey
listed at 249 to pound in October 2022
at L Blas today it's going for the exact
same
price but that might be a steal compared
to what independent groceries can sell
for this turkey nearly four times the
price at
$77 high prices the manager of farmers
pick in Ottawa blames on fuel costs and
supply chain issues eggs are like like
triple what they were 3 years ago we've
had I think seven or eight pric
increases in 12 months where generally
there's one a year four for5 breakfast
their persistent price pressures leaving
many Canadians to make difficult choices
once you are alone then with the small
pension that has to last you the month
not very easy food for us is a luxury
the biggest concrete measure the
industry Minister announced a new task
force to check grocery prices monthly to
see if costs are actually coming down
and if they don't Donna the Finance
Minister threatens special taxes on the
grocery
chains okay McKenzie gray in Ottawa
thank you prime minister Justin trudo
was in vaugh Ontario today that city is
the second to sign a deal with the
federal government for the National
Housing accelerator fund intended to
help FastTrack the building of new
homes we all know that if we want people
to succeed we need more homes in vaugh
we need more homes across the GTA we
need more homes right across the country
the city will get over $59 million to
assist in the construction of over 1,700
homes in the next 3 years Apartments
affordable housing and high density
developments near Transit will get
priority it is a fraction of what's
needed to combat Canada's housing crisis
according to the Canada mortgage and
housing Corporation the country will
need 3.5 million additional units by
2030 to restore
affordability tragedy strikes a
celebration in Syria coming up the
attack on a milit AR college graduation
ceremony in Syria a drone strike has
killed more than 100 people who were
taking part in a graduation ceremony at
a military
academy it happened in the western city
of Holmes both civilians and military
personnel were killed dozens of others
were wounded it has been more than 12
years since civil war broke out in Syria
hundreds of thousands of people have
died millions are displaced no group has
claimed responsibility for this attack
at least 18 people have been killed and
nearly 100 others are missing after
heavy rains caused a Himalayan glacial
Lake in Northeast India to burst its
banks the Raging Water washed away 14
Bridges making rescuing those caught in
the flood waters more difficult 98
people are missing at least 20 are
believed to be Army Personnel the region
has received over 101 mm of rain since
the start of this month more than double
normal levels too hot to handle ahead
why scientists are worried after the
world's extraordinarily warm
September another Heat record has been
set on Earth and this one is by the
largest margin yet the EU climate
service says the global average surface
air temperature reached 16 38° in
September that's 93° above the average
September temperatures for the past 30 2
years and half a degree hotter than the
previous record set in 2020 the
September numbers follow the hottest
summer since records began a four-month
stretch that's put 2023 firmly on track
to be the hottest year in history Eric
Sorenson
explains the leaves are changing the
seasonal reminders are out and the Sun
is at the low angle you expect in
October but something's not normal it's
September and late now it's October and
it's summer yes in this country going
shirtless at the beach in October seems
great but it's possible that this is not
good for the planet indeed the planet's
temperature last month was an astounding
1.8 de C above pre-industrial levels the
reason persistent global warming with an
extra injection of heat this year from
the Pacific elino current we have been
warming the Earth's temperature yearly
at this point so when enino occurs we're
augmenting that heat due to climate
change but what's very different about
September is that those records were
just shattered the eu's cernus satellite
and land and ocean and Atmospheric data
is increasingly alarming here are the
Earth's surface air temperature
comparisons for the last 83 septembers
for almost 70 years the anomalies
relative to the period 1991 to 2020 were
cooler than average but look at the last
15 years every September has been warmer
than average close to half a degree
and this September almost a full degree
Cel above that
average Canada is already seeing the
extreme impacts of climate change
Atlantic hurricanes wildfires from east
to west and melting arctic ice we're
simply not doing enough say experts to
bring down carbon emissions governments
the fossil fuel industry and all of us
as individuals this is what the data is
telling us it's telling us that we need
to be doing so much more and we need to
be doing it faster there has to be
regulations we need to have a big shift
it means a total change of Paradigm
changing the way we work the way we live
that's the only way we can really really
stop this so we can and should enjoy the
mild Autumn but climate scientists point
out that a warm dry fall and winter
could bring the same conditions next
year that saw disasters this year in
short this is not normal and not
necessarily a good omen for the future
Eric senson Global News
Toronto
Commander is no longer living at the
White House the presidential pup bit a
secret service agent last week and he
has a habit of it in the last year the
2-year-old German Shepherd has nipped at
least 11 people a spokesperson for first
lady Jill Biden says the bidens care
deeply about the safety of those who
work at the White House there is no word
on where Commander is living
now next the Canadian connection to the
brightest attraction in Las
Vegas
the newest concert venue in Las Vegas
has quickly become one of the most
photographed attractions in the world
the sphere Towers over other structures
in Las Vegas and it intertwines culture
technology science and art what you may
not know about the $3 billion building
is the contribution made by a Canadian
company Mike Armstrong
explains they are kind of impressive to
see close up dozens of light pucks each
with 48 LEDs flashing in the Montreal
Factory where they were built but what
they do with 1.2 million pucks is well
eye popping during The Last 5 Years of
our life it is what we've been focusing
on and the results are astonishing
Jonathan Le is the co-ceo of seyo
Technologies the Canadian company was
hired at first to do the outside of the
sphere and then later the inside it's a
different sort of Technology boards
instead of pucks but just as of
impressive the venue opened officially
with a YouTu show Friday making use of a
video screen with
1070 million pixels it's the highest
resolution of any screen of any sort in
the world the Seiko team knew what their
screen could do and say they were still
shocked yeah I'm going to say it was H I
mean it was
[Music]
mind-blowing the idea came from a sketch
by the executive director of Madison
Square Garden James Dolan he also owns
the New York Knicks and New York Rangers
he and his team wanted to create a new
entertainment venue in Vegas they looked
at different shapes a pyramid a box even
a muffin before settling on the sphere
this is experiential you know it's
something that people haven't ever felt
before and I believe they're going to
love it the sphere is set to premere a
new movie Friday postcard from Earth is
directed by Darren aronowski every image
was shot specifically for the round
format not only did we create the screen
for MSG but MSG then had to create a
special camera system so Innovation all
around aronofsky's movie is part sci-fi
part nature documentary it's going to
run for a year but the years to come
will be interesting it's hard not to
wonder what artists will do with the
sphere and what other cities might want
their own Mike armstr Global News
Montreal something else and that is
global national for this Thursday I'm
Donna freezen tonight's your candidate
is Victoria BC which according to
readers of condas Traveler magazine is
the best small city in the world largely
because the city it says Embraces
Adventure thanks for watching
[Music]
bye-bye